we're getting right to it because we are
very excited to have actor Sean Hayes
here with us today is joining us as part
of our road to the Tony's coverage where
we count down to Broadway's biggest
night the Tony Awards air June 11th
right here on CBS and Hayes is nominated
for best actor in a play for his role in
good night Oscar based on the real life
of actor comedian and pianist Oscar
Levant he was a household name in the
1950s and struggled with mental health
issues and also addiction the play takes
place in 1958 when levant's wife signed
him out of a psychiatric hospital to
appear on The Tonight Show with Jack
Parr in this clip we see Hayes as Levant
chatting with Parr during the broadcast
so uh bring us up to date Oscar what
have you been doing with yourself lately
well my behavior has been impeccable
I've been unconscious for the last six
months really but flat out on your back
yeah I'm in the middle of a breakdown
it's my fifth and two years sorry to
hear it well don't be that's the thing
about schizophrenia yes
it sure beats dining alone
John Hayes joins us now Sean thank you
so much for being here thank you for
having me might I start out by saying
nothing says Morning Show like a bowl of
succulents
there you go yeah you're welcome thank
you that's incredible I feel like I'm in
the desert are you saying we need to do
something no no it looks very real I was
I was here thinking I was thinking uh is
that a line from the play
is he referencing your intro
damn you suck anyway
about this I was about to shower you
with praise congratulations on the Tony
thank you thank you and we're all uh
nomination yeah nomination uh yes
nomination
um uh we are I'm amazed at the
transformation that you undergo to play
Oscar and then the transformation back
to yourself to appear here today I mean
it's tell us about getting into this
role which I know was written for you
and I know it's been in production for
for decades right yeah various uh ways
so but the transformation talk to us
about that yeah well it was it's a it's
a lot of work it was um lots of hours of
watching archival footage at the Paley
Center in Los Angeles reading all his
books which she's a phenomenal writer
people don't realize that too or forget
about that um but for me it was it's I I
was the youngest of five kids so all I
did was Observe and I grew up around a
lot of addiction and some mental health
issues so I absorbed it as a kid Irish
Catholics so everybody was an alcoholic
and so um so I I I kind of got to get in
trouble yeah I was gonna say same yeah
you're drunk now is what you told me
about before we started uh no but um so
so for me it's it's almost therapeutic
to play something like this and kind of
I get something out of it too I get to
get out all the stuff that I I had
observed when I was a kid so and and
Oscar you know it was once said by I
forget who who uh somebody famous but it
they said if he did not exist he could
not be imagined because he was such an
incredible character and it's such an
exciting thing for me
now being such a massive fan of his uh
to introduce him to people and also for
those who do remember and remind him who
he was I know it's called acting Sean
but for some
were known as Jack from willing Grace
jazz hands yeah I mean this is such a
big departure to people did you find
people believe that you could pull off
this character because this Tony said
you were you were so good oh thank you I
appreciate it yeah for me it's a swing
swing for the fences right because it's
like you know it could be like a uh oh
what's he doing with the voice and the
thing the shaking and the right so but
I'm at an age in a time in my life where
if you're gonna go for it you got to go
forward here for five minutes all of us
you know and so big or go home yeah for
sure you know what struck me as a piano
playing I didn't know that you because
clearly I'm sitting here that is he
really playing the piano yeah yeah I was
really wondering about that yeah yeah I
was uh studied since I was five years
old and uh do you hear if the audience
Wonders that too yeah yeah like the
first five rows you go every single
night every night so I start playing the
Rhapsody In Blue in the first five rows
is like
[Music]
you hear that yeah
by the way everybody who comes to any
Broadway show yes we can hear you
and see you it's like it's so funny that
people think they're all they're like
there's a wall it's like no that's what
they call it the fourth wall yeah so
they doubt it but you're classically
trained yeah yeah yeah I studied for 15
20. yeah actually Nate we have a video
of you icing your hands after yeah some
of these performances because it's
scrolling stuff yeah I so before and
after right yeah before and after I I
ice before my hands um what does it do
for you
reduces the inflammation and because I
don't think you're supposed to play the
Rhapsody in Blue
seven times a week five months yeah yeah
so it takes a toll on my forearms and my
hands and so even like even doing this
because Gershwin for the music nerds out
there he would he wrote and said he had
such big hands so he'd write intense you
know octaves are just one you know you
know what an octave is yeah so stretch
it two more yeah notes and you're using
your whole so I'm constantly like this
yeah the whole time so that's you know
this character is is very layered
um as he was in real life and IT
addresses so many things mental health
addiction
um who he was
how does playing this role help you
address your own mental health yeah well
I mean I I kind of touched on that with
Gail is
um
you know I I by the way since the
pandemic it seems like everybody
struggles with men with anxiety and
depression yeah so um I certainly fell
victim to that as well as as always
having anxiety I have massive anxiety so
um I I understand that part of Oscar so
um incorporating his shaking and his uh
Twitches as he got older which was a
reaction to the abuse of um of
medication prescription pills he used to
make one joke saying I take prescription
pills for the side effects
one of those one-liners he had a billion
of them but um so yeah I relate to that
I relate to anxiety and this definitely
the second I walk out on stage I get to
incorporate my own anxiety into the part
yeah are you going to go to the uh Tony
Awards uh I mean there's a big strike
going on yeah they I don't know if you
heard things they got a waiver yeah
I was glad about that because yeah for
this is huge for the Tony business
because for many of them this is how
they get to see the place yeah and and
so much of Broadway relies on the Tony
Awards to advertise to America what's
going on over here yeah so I think it's
it's it's dare I say a little different
not entirely but a little different
because the core business of Broadway
and a lot of New York City the economy
of New York City depends on this so it's
kind enough uh of the wga to give the
waiver I think and everybody said you're
supporting the writers absolutely
absolutely and Sean when Tony said
congratulations on the Tony he was
speaking into existence yeah well it's
all benefits
I'm just kidding you know we do wish you
luck it's a great great performance it's
a great play uh if you like Broadway
you're gonna love this if you like old
school TV you're also going to find a
lot here and if you like Sean Hayes and
it's like Sean Hayes yes although it
doesn't look like himself he's
transformed uh Sean thank you very much
for being here appreciated thank you for
having me good night Oscar currently
playing at the Belasco Theater on
Broadway and be sure to watch the 76
next annual Tony Awards June 11th at 8
pm Eastern right here on CBS uh and
streaming on Paramount Plus